زلزال تركيا وسوريا لازال العنوان الاول
العلماء مختلفين حول نظريات تفسر الزلزال
ومو عارفين اجلس صدق منها واستنكار عالمي
لسخريه صحيفه شعله الفرنسيه من ضحايا
الزلزال اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
مستمرين معكم مشاهدينا في تغطيه مستجدات
الكارثه الطبيعيه والانسانيه اللي سببها
الزلزال المدمر اللي ضرب جنوب تركيا وشمال
سوريا بقوه 7.8 الضحايا الان تجاوز 11 الف
و 700 قتيل وعشرات الالاف من الجرحى في كل
من البلدين عمليات البحث عن الناجين لا
زالت مستمره وحسبت تصريحات ففي الالاف من
الاشخاص عالقين تحت الانقاض والسبب غير
نقص المعدات في سوريا وحجم الدمار الكبير
كمان سوء الاحوال الجويه في تركيا وسوريا
واللي جالس بعرق العمليات البحث وكان
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان طلع وقال
انه الحكومه التركيه تعاقدت مع عدد من
الفنادق في انطاليا علشان يجلسوا فيهم
الناس الناجين والمتضررين من الزلزال واكد
راح يتم دفع تعويضات لهم وانه خلال عام
راح يتم اعاده اعمار المناطق المدمره
المعونات هو المساعدات مستمره لسوريا
وتركيا من عدد كبير من الدول العربيه
والاجنبيه هذا غير المنظمات اللي اعلنت عن
دعمها للمتضررين ومطارات تركيا وسوريا ما
وقفت استقبال طائرات بتحمل المساعدات
ومن ساعات اعلى المركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه عن تسيير جسر
جوي وتقديم مساعدات صحيه وايوائيه وغذائيه
لتخفيف اثار الزلزال على المتضررين في
سوريا وتركيا بالاضافه لتنظيم حمله شعبيه
هي الاولى من نوعها لجمع التبرعات
للمتضررين من كلا الشعبين عبروا منصات
ساهم وصلت قيمتها ل 13 مليون ريال او 13
مليون ريال في اقل من 24 ساعه من وقت
الاعلان عنها
هذه الحمله سوف
تشكل برامج متعدده سوف يستفاد من هذه
المبالغ من برامج متعدده وجه بها المقام
الكريم لخادم الحرمين الشريفين ولي عهد
الامين سوف يدشن جسر جوي خلال الساعات
القادمه باذن الله لحمل التبرعات سواء
كانت ايوائيه او صحيه او غذائيه كما سوف
تقوم فرق الانقاذ
بالسفر الى مواقع الحدث
لانقاذ المصابين والمتضررين من هذا
الزلزال وسوف تكون هنالك فرق تدخل سريع
وفرق طوارئ طبيه ذات تدخل سريع وكذلك فرق
تطوعيه من الكوادر السعوديه التي تبرعت
بوقتها وجهدها وخبرتها لتخفيف المصاب الذي
اصاب الاشقاء في سوريا وتركيا كما اننا
سوف نحمل ما نستطيع من مواد ايوائيه وكذلك
غذائيه وصحيه وفقا لما تقوم به فرق
التقييم التي وجه بها خادم الحرمين
الشريفين لتقييم الاحتياج الانساني الذي
يستطيع منها فريق مركز الملك سلمان والفرق
الاخرى لدعم هذه التدخل
ومن وقت ما صار الزلزال الرئيس المدمر
واحنا بنسمع عن مئات الهزات الارتداديه
وحتى زلازل جديده كمان فسمعنا اول يوم عن
زلزال ثاني جنوب تركيا بقوه 7.7 وزلزال
ثالث تركيا بقوه 5.6 واليوم سمعنا عن
زلزال رابع كمان في لواء اسكندرون بقوه
4.5 وطبعا ما يحتاج نشرح قديش اخبار
الزلازل الجديده هذه عامله حاله رعب عند
الناس وقبل دقائق مشاهدينا نقلت وكاله
الانباء الفرنسيه اخبار عن توقف عمل منصه
تويتر عبر شركات الاتصالات في تركيا وقيل
انه الحكومه حضرت الموقع او تويتر تحديدا
يعني على خلفيه الانتقادات الموجهه
للحكومه هناك بسبب تعاملها مع كارثه
الزلزال هذه المعلومات بنذكر مشاهدينا ان
وفقا لوكاله لم يتسنى لنا التحقق منها حتى
الان لانه وردت الان ولكن طبعا ستكون من
الاخبار اللي حتكون معانا في الفتره
القادمه يعني
[موسيقى]
تداول اخبار الزلزال ومستجدات عمليات
الانقاذ واعداد الضحايا واخبار الزلازل
الجديده كمان لسه الناس بتدور على
النظريات تفسر فيها اللي صار في حلقه امس
ناقشنا بعض النظريات اللي الناس جالسه
بتعملها او على الاقل بتساءل يعني بتتساءل
عنها او بخصوصها مثل توقف لب الارض عن
الدوران وعلاقته بالزلزال او تصرفات غريبه
لبعض الحيوانات والزلزال او مرور المذنب
الاخضر بالقرب من الارض لاول مره من خمسين
سنه وعلاقته بالزلزال والملفت انه يعني
رغم انه في علماء كثار بينفوا اي علاقات
بين هذه الامور
والزلازل لكن في ناس ثانيه شايفه العكس
تماما وما بتكلم هنا عن ناس عاديه انا
بتكلم عن مختصين وخبراء وعلماء اناس دارسه
مو ناس بتقول رايها يعني فمثلا في ناس
مصره ان المذنب له علاقه بالزلزال وبيتاكد
انه هو السبب وبتقول كمان انه هذا التفسير
عدد الزلازل الكبيره اللي صارت وسمعنا
عنها من وقت الزلزال المدمر لل
اولا السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
نتقدم باحر التعازي من اهالي الضحايا اللي
سقطوا
عظم الله اجرهم وان شاء الله بتكون بتكون
نهايه الاحزان على سطح الكوكب ولكن مثل ما
كان عم بحكي اليوم اليوم لعلماء العلماء
اللي بيفكروا مزبوط واللي بيبحثوا واللي
عندهم بحث تاريخي عن هذا الموضوع بيقدروا
يوصلوا يعرفوا الحقيقه اين هي اليوم بدنا
نبلش التاريخ الصيني والتاريخ الفارسي
والتاريخ العربي والتاريخ اللي من 3000
سنه لليوم يلي بينحكى فيه عن ما يعرف بنجم
ابو ذنب كانوا يقولوا نجم ابو ذنب كانوا
عندنا بينحكى عن وصول مذنب ما معين على
صدد بالقرب من كوكب الارض او المشاهده
بالعين المجرده كانوا يقولوا فورا انه جاي
الزلازل جايه الفيضانات جايه الحروب كانوا
خافوا كثير
ولكن اليوم بدي اقول اصحاب العلم بيعرفوا
الحقيقه اكثر اليوم نحن انا شخصيا متاكد
من دخول كوكب من دخول المذنب الاخضر
حوالي
للقرب من المجموعه الشمسيه
وتاثيره الخطير جدا بكل تاكيد انكتب من
شهر او من 25 يوم شو راح تعمل بالارض
يا ايها النجم النجم الاخضر كان جوابي كان
جوابي التالي بكل تاكيد زلازل وهزيت ارضيه
وفيضانات
لانه الكوكب ايوه
الرابط كل كوكب مهما يكون عنده طاقته
الجاذبيه عنده طاقته الجاذبيه طاقه
الجاذبيه اللي بده يشتغل عليها والجاذبيه
بين الكواكب الى دور كتير كبير بحركه
بحركه بحركه الطبقات التكتونيه بضمن ضمن
الكواكب
باول اول حدث صار انه كان في تاثير شاب
بشكل مباشر على الحركه التكتونيه الموجوده
يلي ادت الى زلزال خطير جدا دمر منطقه
بشكل كامل اثنين
وين صار شو صار يعني بنفس بنفسها اليومين
اللي ما كانت تسير في ارتباط الارضيه
والزلازل في اماكن كان في عندنا بروسيه
بروسيه زلزال بقوه 5.3 بجزر 5.2 درجه
4.7 درجات على الحدود الصينيه كمان هزه
اربعه فاصله خمس درجات كمان بالمتن
الشمالي بلبنان
غزه صارت ثلاثه
عدد الزلازل في هذا الوقت تحديدا مرتبطه
بمرور المذنب في هذا الوقت تحديدا
انا بسال قبل بس بسال السؤال التالي خلينا
ما نفكر هيك ليه من ثلاثه اشهر ما كانوا
موجودين الليله عند مسار زلزال تركيا
وبنفس بنفس التلات ايام او ثلاثه ايام
صاروا مع العلم انه بمنطقه شارع اذا اخذنا
زلزال لبنان وزلزال نابلس لا يرتبطان
مطلقا بسلسله تركيا من هون بنكون عرفنا
الحقيقه العلميه طيب دكتور انت عارف انه
في كثير ناس بيخلفوك في هذه النظريه
وبيقولوا انه ما في شيء اي علمي بيثبت هذا
الكلام
نحن عم نحكي علم نحن عم نحكي علم انه
يعرفوا يعرفوا درجه طاقه الجاذبيه من كل
كوكب موجود بدي اعطي شكله واضح لو القمر
عنا هون القمر الكوكب الكوكب القريب لالنا
لو ما كان عنده الجزبيه شو كانت حياه
الارض انا بدي اسال سؤال تاني جاوبوني اذا
الامر ما عنده الجاذبيه شو حياه الارض اذا
الكواكب الاخرى اللي ما عندهم معلومات عن
الكواكب ودرجه الجاذبيه بكل كوكب وحركه
الجاذبيه بين الكواكب ما بيقدروا يحكوا
على هيدا المستوى الوقت بس دكتور كنت حابه
اسالك كمان على موضوع التغير المناخي هل
في اي رابط بينه وبين ما يحدث الان من
زلازل
بكل تاكيد للتغير المناخي شيء اخر تغير
المناخي هو يتاثر تتاثر الكتل الهوائيه
بحراره عاليه وبوجود غازات دفيئه بشكل
عالي ولكن لا تاثير مطلقا على الزلازل من
تغير المناخير الان المناخير
من الزلازل او خلاص بما انه يعني
اخر الشهر
تاثيره على على الكوكب راح يضل لاخر الشهر
وان شاء الله ما يكون عنا درجه درجه زلازل
بالنسبه بنسبه عاليه جدا تكون درجات بسيطه
مثل ما صار بنابلس متل ما صار بالمتن ومثل
ما صار على كازاخستان وعلى حدود الصين
واماكن اخرى ان شاء الله ما تكون ما تكون
درجه الخطوره اكثر من هيك ولكن بدي حزر
وبدي شدد على نقطة كتير مهمه المفروض دول
العالم كلها تاخد تاخد القرار السليم جدا
وهو اذا نحن مستعدين نقدمه مجانا لكل دول
العالم
دراسه جديده جدا
ومعلومات عن كل مدينه درجه الابنيه اللي
فيها قد ايه بتتحمل هالزيت وقديش بتتحمل
درجه خطورتها هل في ابنيه بتتحمل سبع
درجات او من درجات هزه او كل هون بتحملوا
في عاجل موجود على قناه العربيه الان يعني
انه اردوغان او الرئيس التركي بيقولوا انه
لم يكن ممكن الاستعداد لكارثه بهذه
الضخامه
فالنوعيه الدراسات اللي بتتحدث عنها
مستحيل حضرتك بتخالفه
ممكن الاستعداد ممكن نعمل الاستعداد
لدراسات شامله مطلق بالمستقبل انه تكون كل
مدننا كل بكل كورونا هي
الابنيه الموجوده فيها تتحمل درجه زلازل
عاليه متل ما وصلت اليابان اليابان دوله
وامريكا المتحده الامريكيه وغسلوا لعندهم
عندهم عندهم ابنيه تتحمل تتحمل درجات
تتحمل زلازل بقوه درجات تسع درجات على
مقياس ريختر في حال وضعت استراتيجيه لكل
الدول تنفذ ابنيه بنفس المواصفات بنكون
نحن امنا لجيل مستقبلي جيل مستقبلي ما
عنده ما عنده اي خوف من الزلازل القادمه
وهيدا الموضوع لازم يكون على محمل جد ضمن
جامعه الدول العربيه ودول نضم للمنطقه
العربيه من اجل وضع استراتيجيات جديده من
وضع جهوزيه جديده للتعامل للتعامل مع
الكوارث انا بدي اقول انه اليوم في حال
حصل كوارث بمناطق ما معينه ما عندهم
الجهوزي ما عنده الخطط المواجهه ما عنده
المعدات المطلوبه وبكل تاكيد راح يدفع
الشعب العربي اسمين غاليين ولكن بدي بدي
شدد على نقطه مجلس التعاون الخليجي عنده
جهوزيه وعندهم استراتيجيه وعندهم عمل جده
جدا نتمنى من الدول العربيه الاخرى انه
يكون عندها نفس الجوزيه ونفس الاستعداد
وبدي يتقدم بالشكر كثير كبير لكل المنطقه
العربيه اللي بلشت تقدم مساعدات مساعدات
لا
للناجين والمساعدات للمناطق المنكوبه طبعا
بيشهد على الكرم وعلى فعل الخير وعلى
المحبه والاخوه تحيه مني وباسم بالبيئه
العالمي الف كلمه شكر طيب بنشكرك على هذه
المداخله كان معنا من بيروت دكتور دومه
كامل رئيس حزب البيئه العالمي شكرا لك
ومن بين كل الاخبار عن الزلزال والدول
اللي اعلنت تضامنها وتعاطفها مع المتضررين
من هذه الكارثه الماساويه طلعت شعله ابدوء
الفرنسيه صاحبه التاريخ الطويل في
الرسومات الكاريكتيريه الجدليه واللي
بتتهم كثير من الاحيان بانها مسيئه طلعت
الصحيفه اليوم برسم جدلي جديد حقيقه اقل
ما يوصف انه يعني بدون احساس والرسم عامل
حاله من الاستنكار حول العالم تجاهه
الصحيفه فالصحيفه صخرت في الزلزال او صخره
من الزلزال في رسمها الالكتروني اليوم
وبعد ساعات بس من وقوع الزلزال المدمر
فنشرت رسم في دمار وانقاض وعنونته زلزال
تركيا وكتبت تحتها لم نضطر حتى لارسال
دبابات المقصود طبعا واضح تمني الدمار
لتركيا وانه ما في داعي يحاربوها او
يرسلوا دبابات لتدميرها لانه خلص او لانه
خلاص الزلزال دمرها الانتقادات والاستنكار
نزلت على الصحيفه من كل مكان في حرفيا من
مشاهير مواطنين سياسيين وغيرها واسمها
تحول الترند حول العالم وعلى فكره منتقدي
الصحيفه منهم كثير ناس سبق وتضامنوا معها
لمن تعرضت لهجمات من متطرفين
المقاطع والصور المؤلمه لضحايا وجرحى
ودمار الزلازل كثيره لكن رغم الالم
والتعاسه لمالي الاجواء في كثير منها في
على الجانب الاخر مقاطع كان فيها نهايات
سعيده فقرتنا الجايه مخصصينا لمقاطع من
هذا النوع يعني لعل وعسى ناخذ جرعه من
الامل وسط كل هذا الالم اللي جالس بيصير
حوالينا في مقطع انتشر حول العالم لطفل
حديث الولاده طلعوا من تحت الانقاض في
جنديرس في ادلب
الطفل الرضيع هذا اتضح انه بنت بنت ولدتها
امها تحت الانقاض واثناء ما كان الناس
بيبحثوا عنا جين سمعوا صوت بكاهه ويلقوها
والحبل السري ما زال موصول بوالدتها اللي
للاسف توفيت مو بس الام حتى الاب وباقي
افراد العائله توف وهو الرضيعه هي الوحيده
اللي نجت وحاليا في حضانه في احدى
المستشفيات بتعاني من خدوش في وجهها
واضلاعها لكن بشكل عام حالتها مستقره وفق
الاطباء رغم العشر ساعات اللي قضتهم تحت
الانقاض قبل ما يتم انقاذها
هاي البنت في معك قدمي شديده على الظهر مع
التورم يعني غالبا متعرضه على تحت من تحت
العنقود متعربه لضغط او ساقط على اي شيء
قدمي كتير واضحه وكتير كبيره في معك خدمات
بالاذن بالوجه بالجبهه في خدمات الاضلاع
نور طفله اخرى مقاطعها قطعت القلب لما
كانوا بيحاولوا ينقذوها وهي عالقه بين
الانقاض ولكن نجحوا اخيرا في اخراجهم
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
بسم الله
في مقطع ثاني كمان اثر في الملايين لطفله
واخوها مو بس علشان كانت حاضنته وحاميه
راسه تحت يدها لكن كمان بسبب الكلام اللي
قالته للمنقذ وهي بتترجى يطلعها
تعرف تلعب العاب
لكش شو
الاء يا الاء انا ولا كلمه انا احسن منك
اذا جبت شو
طالعين
الطفله الاء واخوها رجعوا وفرحوا الناس
لما انتشرت لهم صور بعد انقاذهم وواضح
فيها انه حالتهم الحمد لله مستقره
وغير الرضيعه اللي ولدت تحت الانقاض وغير
نور وغير الاء واخوها في مقاطع منتشره
كثيره بتبعث على الامل حتى وسط كل الوجع
والحزن من الكارثه مقاطع بنشوف فيها حالات
انقاذ لناس ومنهم اطفال لهم اكثر من 72
ساعه تحت الانقاض مع هذه الحلقات او مع
هذه اللقطات بننهي حلقه تفاعلكم لليوم
[تصفيق]
يلا يا عم يلا دقيقه دقيقه بس دقيقتين يلا
يا رب
يلا يلا
الحمد لله على السلامه الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
الله اكبر يا رب يا رب
الحمد لله الحمد لله رب العالمين الحمد
لله
ما تخاف قول يا رب
انت شامله كمان
[موسيقى]